[Music]
even the most talented actors have found
themselves giving an awful performance
can you name the acclaimed actor who was
head over heels for adam sandler dressed
up as a woman or the famous actor and
talk show host who was legally forced to
team up with a talking dinosaur keep
watching for more
for such an awful movie battlefield
earth features some pretty amazing
actors including barry pepper and john
travolta but if we had to pick the best
actor to appear in this piece of sci-fi
garbage it's hard to argue with forest
whitaker the man won an oscar for his
powerful performance as the insane
dictator idiamine in the last king of
scotland he was the essence of cool in
ghost dog way of the samurai he tore at
our heartstrings in the crying game and
he grabbed everybody's attention with
his leading role in bird what's such a
talented guy doing in one of the worst
reviewed films of all time a movie based
on a novel written by the man who
created scientology no less the answer
is simple he was delivering the worst
performance of his career playing kerr
an oversized alien with dreams of
getting rich whitaker is forced to drop
insults like corporate crap heads and
earnestly wonder why humans enjoy eating
rats if this were a comedy maybe it
would work but it's supposed to be
deadly serious so when whitaker delivers
his lines in caveman fashion it comes
off as unintentionally hilarious
[Laughter]
stupid humans his only saving grace is
that he's partially shielded by
travolta's insane performance as the
power hungry turtle of course even if
whitaker was doing an amazing job it
hardly would have mattered as he's
buried under some pretty terrible makeup
jesse eisenberg wowed everyone when he
played mark zuckerberg in the social
network while we could argue all day
about the accuracy of david fincher's
film there's no denying eisenberg gave a
powerhouse of a performance he was even
nominated for a best actor oscar in
addition to playing the social media
mogul eisenberg has left his mark on
movies like the double roger dodger the
end of the tour and the squid and the
whale but every great actor has their
cinematic kryptonite and in eisenberg's
case that's batman vs superman dawn of
justice the curly-haired star won a
worst supporting act for razzie for his
performance as lex luthor a role that
was probably better suited for someone
older and more menacing honestly
eisenberg is the worst luther of all
time especially when compared to the
likes of gene hackman and michael
rosenbaum eisenberg was just too loud
and manic to play the man of steel's
arch enemy and honestly he would have
done a far better job as the riddler the
joker putting a new spin on a classic
character was a risky move on
eisenberg's part and sadly it just
didn't pay off
for more than a decade halle berry was
one of the most likable stars in
hollywood she starred in comedies like
boomerang serviceable dramas like losing
isaiah and action spectaculars like
x-men then she delivered an absolutely
devastating gut punch of a performance
in the sad engrossing 2001 indie movie
monsters ball her work is leticia
musgrove the grieving widow of an
executed convict falling in love with
her husband's executioner won bury an
academy award for best actress but the
kind of showy meaty scripts befitting a
newly minted oscar winner didn't follow
for barry after monster's ball barry was
a bond girl and die another day played
storm in another x-men movie and
co-starred in the horror flick gothica
then in 2004 she played the titular
character in the batman spin-off
catwoman the film consists mainly of
barry shredding around gotham city in a
tight flesh-bearing cat suit smirking to
herself as she commits crimes and avoids
capture keith phipps of the av club
wrote catwoman is essentially an excuse
to pose barry in ever skimpier outfits
barry at least tried to save this bomb
of a movie and give it her best andrea
thompson of the spool argued some sort
of acting category should have been
created just for her and the amount of
effort she spent trying to salvage the
unsalvageable putting her all into every
idiotic line oops
my bad barry herself called catwoman a
quote piece of
and a god-awful movie when she accepted
her razzie award for worst actress in
person in the first half of the 1980s
eddie murphy was the hottest star on tv
dominating saturday night live with
hilarious characters like velvet jones
buckwheat and mr robinson then he became
a major movie star headlining classic
comedies of the 80s and 90s including
beverly hills cop trading places coming
to america and the nutty professor after
some box office bombs such as the
adventures of pluto nash and i spy eddie
murphy was back on top of hollywood in
2006. he earned plaudits for his rare
dramatic turn as a tragic 60s r b singer
in the 2006 movie adaptation of musical
dream girls murphy received his first
ever academy award nomination and he was
predicted by oscar pundits and experts
to triumphantly take home a statuette
but then norbit came along apparently
derailing everything don't you think i
realize what's going on here miss murphy
starred in norbit as the titular
character a nerdy doormat who falls into
an abusive relationship with a mean
woman named rasputia lattimore with the
aid of prosthetics and a
cringe-inducing fake accent murphy also
portrayed chinese orphanage caretaker mr
wong and with makeup wigs and a fat suit
played respiration too critics hate it
the fart joke heavy norbit a film with a
9 rating on rotten tomatoes it's also
entirely possible that academy award
voters seeing norbit everywhere thought
twice about checking the box for murphy
alan arkin ultimately won best
supporting actor for little miss
sunshine over murphy
in 2003 it had become something of a
national pastime to rag on gili part
romantic comedy part mob movie
potentially insulting to the lgbtq
community italians disabled people and
who knows how many other groups gili was
indeed a very bad movie jennifer lopez
portrayed ricky a charming gangster set
to help out an inept low-level mob goon
said goon was tasked with kidnapping the
mentally disabled brother of a federal
prosecutor going after their syndicate
ricky is gay but she somehow can't
resist the charms of affleck's geely a
sputtering clownish italian-american
stereotype the independent critic found
affleck so terrific in argo gone girl
the way back and goodwill hunting as did
many others so to see as the outlet put
it that affleck had no chemistry with
lopez was disappointing especially since
she was his fiancee at the time joel
siegel of abc news boldly wrote ben
affleck an oscar-winning screenwriter is
a man of many talents i'm not sure
acting is among them
in a career filled with silly high
concept comedies loathed by critics adam
sandler's jack and jill has the
impressive distinction of being the most
poorly reviewed theatrical film he has
ever made it earned a woeful three
percent on rotten tomatoes it was also
the first movie to sweep the razzie
awards winning 10 prizes for ineptitude
in film sandler plays the titular twins
both of them utterly unlikable a
workaholic commercial producer and his
obnoxious loud emotionally fragile
sister but while sandler's broad style
doesn't feel out of place in the wacky
physical comedy-oriented flick al pacino
sure does pacino works on a completely
different level in the adam sandler
comedy surprisingly known for the
intense skills he put to good use in
cinematic touchstones like dog day
afternoon serpico and the godfather
films those same skills simply paint
pacino as unhinged in jack and jill but
what's strange is that pacino's worst
performance has him miss playing himself
the sole motivation of his character to
romance jill adam sandler and women's
clothes than a wig leaves him with
nothing to work with all we see is a
perverse fascination with an utterly
unappealing woman pacino aggressively
makes unwanted advances toward jill
groping her touching her and trying to
show her how to play brooklyn style
stickball though he does take breaks to
go off on long meandering mumbled
tangents about his life work and wealth
with a wide and wild-eyed stare that
uncomfortably penetrates other
characters and the audience too
after starring in masterpieces like taxi
driver the godfather part 2 the deer
hunter and raging bull robert de niro
built up a legendary career as one of
the most respected actors of his
generation he followed that up by
spending most of the new millennium
playing grumpy old men this strategy may
have worked out commercially with meet
the parents and its sequels but not so
much with the big wedding everybody's
fine the war with grandpa or dirty
grandpa de niro so frequently the
orchestrator of singular roles with
singular talent and detail has been
reduced to portraying the cliched lusty
old man who wants to party hard and make
viagra jokes he tricks his buttoned-up
grandson into taking him to daytona
beach for spring break festivities he is
in other words exactly what the title
says he is a dirty grandpa flavor wire's
jason bailey called the movie the
absolute nadir of late period robert de
niro which is really saying something
critic richard krauss said it's the kind
of film that one day de niro's great
grandchildren will watch and wonder what
all the fuss about him was
jon voight's career has spanned seven
decades beginning in the 1960s and
exploding with an oscar-nominated
breakout role as a naive sex worker in
the 1969 best picture winner midnight
cowboy a decade later he gave voice to
the experience of hundreds of thousands
of american men as a vietnam war veteran
readjusting to civilian life and coming
home for which he won the oscar for best
actor in 2001 voight was nominated again
for playing howard cosell in the
muhammad ali biopic ali in recent years
voight has turned to tv earning
accolades and awards for his roles on 24
and ray donovan but voight doesn't only
appear in prestigious projects he's a
prolific actor who has sometimes
unapologetically taken paychecks
wherever they present themselves
certainly the rock bottom of his resume
of 100 projects is super babies baby
geniuses 2. voigt plays the villainous
bill biscayne a german tycoon with a bad
blonde wig locked in an endless battle
with a james bond type baby super baby
scored a perfect zero percent on rotten
tomatoes with many critics blaming the
film's awfulness squarely on voight the
austin chronicle called his performance
that of a super hemi nincompoop while
the san francisco chronicles critics
said they felt embarrassed for the actor
usa today said that voigt looked more
comfortable when he was regurgitated in
the snake-based horror movie anaconda
theodore rex is a movie so strange
misbegotten and largely forgotten that
it feels like a fake movie you'd see in
a real one making fun of the
entertainment industry but no whoopie
goldberg really did star in a gritty
police movie about a human and a
dinosaur paired up as detectives trying
to solve a crime in a world where people
and talking dinosaurs coexist whoopi
goldberg played the human half of the
detective duo in theodore rex her
performance as a futuristic police
officer acting opposite a pretend
dinosaur does not rank with her iconic
roles such as in the color purple ghost
or sister act goldberg seems alternately
bored annoyed anxious and wooden and
with good reason after trying to back
out of a promise to star in the movie
producers sued goldberg in 1993. after
much legal wrangling the actor was
essentially forced by the courts to act
in theodore wrecks looking at her
performance all these years later it
sure seems like she was determined to
put in as little effort as humanly
possible thank you sir
cats is an extremely theatrical
experience which is probably why it took
so long to make it into a movie the 2019
film sprawling cast included nearly 80
actors many of whom have won all sorts
of awards and what did director tom
hooper do with so many talented actors
including dame judy dench jennifer
hudson and idris elba he dressed them up
in shabby cat costumes and had them
prance around the sound stage while
singing nonsensical songs about cat life
while cgi technology shrank them down to
cat's eyes the whole idea should have
been relegated to the litter box cats
features such hard to watch scenes as
mckellen best known as the mighty
gandalf in the iconic the lord of the
rings films lamenting his glory days as
a young theater cat katz was nominated
for nine razzie awards with dench
singled out for her particularly
imperfect performance
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
the movies we love to hate are coming
soon subscribe to our youtube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single one